welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we break
down all the latest movies new game
releases TV shows and comic books this
episode we're gonna be covering one of
the most mysterious elements of the new
HBO show Watchmen which is Ozymandias is
plan throughout this video I'm gonna be
giving my fan theory on what exactly is
going on with the character and all of
the evidence to support it there will be
heavy spoilers for the graphic novel and
first three episodes of the show here
and if this turns out to be true then
big ones going forward so if you want to
go into the show as blind as possible
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now if I managed to finally pronounce
Ozymandias properly for the first time
ever in a video then give me a thumbs up
and without further ado let's get into
our breakdown of his plan okay so just a
quick recap of the characters entire
history in case you haven't read the
graphic novel and just want to get up to
speed so Ozymandias real name Adrian
Veidt was a masked vigilante born in
1939 two rich German parents after they
died when the character was 17 he
inherited their fortune but decided to
donate it all to charity choosing to
build himself from the ground up instead
if I travelled the world following in
the footsteps of Alexander the Great and
upon completing his journey decided to
become a crime fighter extremely
intelligent and someone who had trained
their body to peak physical condition
Veidt quickly rose through the ranks
until he became a renowned vigilante
with a reputation for being the smartest
man on the planet when the Keene Act was
put in place which outlawed superheroes
both came forward with his real identity
and name and turned himself into a brand
using the technology he had developed
over the years as a commodity in order
to become a multi billionaire due to his
foresight if I'd realized that with the
arrival of dr. Manhattan the world would
begin to fear America and that this
would increase to a point where nuclear
war was inevitable in order to avert
this bite decided that the best way to
stop the war was to unite everyone in
fighting a common enemy and thus instead
of pointing their arms at one another
they would point them at this one threat
depending on whether you've read the
graphic novel or have seen the film
adaptation this goes one of two ways
with Ozzie framing dr. Manhattan
murdering millions in the movie or
faking an alien invasion by Jane squid
that too caused countless deaths in the
book the latter of which required Ozzy
piling together psychics writers and
artists to create the most fear inducing
being that will unite the planet under
one common enemy and as the show is a
direct sequel to the graphic novel this
is the continuity that I'll be going
with for this video now so far in the
show we know that it is still widely
believed that there was an alien attack
in 1985 though there exists some
conspiracy theories that this was a hoax
as for Veidt himself in 2012 after true
industries purchased his companies the
character went missing following this in
2017 the governor of Vietnam claimed
that the Vietnamese Liberation Front had
assassinated him as an act of terror
against the United States and on
September 9th 2019 White was declared
officially dead however from the show we
know that this very clearly isn't the
case and that bite is still indeed alive
though exactly where he is is up for
debate and I'm gonna be kind of
discussing my fan theory on this as well
as what the character is planning to do
okay so initially it seemed like he was
living in paradise surrounded by
servants living every day like it was
his birthday however as the show has
gone on we've learned that he is indeed
trapped in this place unable to escape
and desperate to get away I think that
it's a safe assumption to make that
someone somewhere has indeed realized or
already knew that
Ozymandias was indeed behind the alien
invasion and they have decided that
imprisonment is the best place for him
they know that he could always unearth
the truth and send the world back to war
and due to this they've moved him to a
place where he is unable to communicate
with anyone those who were aware of the
plan at the end of the graphic novel
were Rorschach who was killed because he
refused to keep quiet about it Laurie
who we now know is an FBI agent Nite Owl
who has been incarcerated and dr.
Manhattan who at the end of the work
decided to leave earth the only one out
of these who seems like he has not only
the means to move Ozymandias but also
trap him in a place that will be
difficult to escape from is dr.
Manhattan in the original graphic novel
and Doc was able to transport her those
to Mars in the blink of an eye and we
know from the first episode of the
series that he has been spotted on the
planet
there are also confessional like booth
sets and messages directly to Mars so
from this we can gather that
indeed there we also see video footage
of the character building what looks to
be a castle on the planet and this bears
a lot of similarities the Ozymandias is
home due to the time that it would take
to get images of the planet and send
them back to earth we can guess that
this isn't live and the footage may be
from months or even years earlier way
back in 2017 when the character went
missing due to his birthdays we do know
that Ozzy's sections in the show are
taking place across several years so it
makes sense that these stay back to 2017
I believe that dr. Manhattan has
kidnapped the character because he is
able to see the future and was carrying
this out because it is what had to be
done in case you don't know dr.
Manhattan can see all time at once
however he can't interfere with it as it
is all preordained and even if he wanted
to change the future he would be unable
to because that is not the way that
things happen basically the line that
sums it up best from the graphic novel
is we are all puppets I can just see the
strings time is cyclical the past is the
present as the present is the past and
yeah a lot of time you why me
wibbly-wobbly stuff anyway because of
this the doc would have known the
outcome of leaving Ozzy on earth and
therefore it makes sense that he would
be moved to Mars but how does that
explain why it looks like Ozzy is in the
lucious countryside surrounded by
endless fields and beautiful landscapes
well in the graphic novel Oz he actually
built something very similar to this in
the Arctic Pole at his palace of Karnak
we see in that that the character
created a giant dome with a luscious
tropical rainforest within it and a
larger version of this could be what's
being used to house him now I am open to
the idea as well as he is still in the
Arctic Pole like how we left him at the
end of the graphic novel trapped in a
dome there I just think Mars seems a bit
more likely due to the fact that dr.
Manhattan was seen building a castle on
the planet but either one of these
locations is inhospitable for humans so
it could really go either way I just
think that by now surveillance on earth
as well as expeditions to the poles
would have picked up on him being there
anyway OSI is clearly trying to escape
this in order to get back to
civilization and nursey has been using
clones at the location to test out the
safest way to do this these clones could
either have been provided by dr.
Manhattan who can create duplicates or
by Ozzy who we know has dabbled in
genetic engineering due to his cat
Bubastis which he
created using science either way OSI has
been using them to test the temperatures
of the environment outside of his prison
and this is why we see the clone in
Episode three come back frozen solid as
he realizes that he needs a thicker skin
and this attempts to use a buffalos hide
though he is stopped by the game warden
who is probably the warden of the prison
yeah the clues in the title the catapult
could potentially be used to throw him
beyond the barrier of the prison into
the cold reaches of space
which he will need a suit for there's
also a theory flowing around that Ozzy
is using all of the bodies of the clones
in order to build a raft this ties in
with the black freighter work from the
source material in which is stranded
sailor uses the corpses of his comrades
in order to build a raft to sail back to
the mainland in that the character goes
mad and ends up murdering his own family
whom he believes had been taken by the
titular black freighter that left him
shipwrecked
and in the story this always had clear
illusion so Ozymandias azar could this
metaphor be running now with the
character attempting to carry out a
similar process to the Sailor in the
book potentially an L Mars is millions
of miles away from Earth so it would be
a long journey but there may also be
crafts space stations and the like
orbiting the planet we know from the
original work that technologically the
world of Watchmen is far more advanced
than our own and they may have the means
to send man craft Amma's there may even
be an outpost on the planet that he is
trying to reach in order to send an SOS
message now I have seen people say that
the doc would know all this and stop him
however the characters foresight has
been limited before by Ozzy who was able
to manipulate tachyons in order to stop
him view in the future in conclusion I
think there is enough evidence here to
support the theory that Ozymandias is on
Mars he is building the means of travel
to escape the planet using whatever
resources that he has around him in
order to reach either an outpost or
another ship so he can finally travel
back to earth the character has the
intelligence means an ability to do this
and though he may be a bit senile
watching him piece it all together is
definitely my favorite part of the show
now obviously I loved hear your thoughts
on this theory and if you agree with my
take on it or have an even better one if
you're from the future and this video
has aged worse since Silk Spectre senior
and make sure you let us know what
really happened
if you enjoyed this then please give a
thumbs up and don't forget to stay
locked to the channel for weekly
breakdowns on every episode of HBO's
Watchmen I leave the playlist of all the
videos so far in the season so if you
need a quick catch-up or just want to
watch a recap then make sure you check
them out you want to come chat to me
after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which will be linked in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with all the latest videos on
the channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
box out on blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
my theory in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen the 15th a
November and the cell be shipped out
from then to ever get surprise so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]